the question we're given asks us how
many students attended Einstein school
in 2006 and this little table they tell
us how many tended in 2001 150 students
and then in 2002 225 2003 we had 300
students but they don't tell us 2006 so
what I think they want us to do is to
see the pattern and how many students
the population of students grew by every
year and this assumed that that pattern
continues through 2006 so we need to
figure out what the pattern is from one
year to the next and then we're going to
figure out 2004 2005 and then 2006 so
the assumption that we're making in this
problem and I think that the problem
wants us to make is that whatever the
pattern of growth was in these three
years that they continue all the way to
2006 so let's see what's happening here
when we go the first year what happens
to our student population we go from 150
to 225 students so the easiest pattern
to think about is well just how much are
we increasing by every year so how much
do we have to go to from 150 to 225 we
increased well if you increase by 50 you
get to 200 so we increased another 25 so
we increased by 75 students and then
they go from 225 to 300 how many did we
increase by looks like 75 again 75 plus
225 is 300 so it looks like we increased
by another 75 so the pattern here is
that each year 75 more students attend
the Einstein School so let's just
continue that pattern so let's add
another 75 let's add another 75 to the
three hundred and two thousand three and
we'll get three hundred and three
hundred and seventy-five in 2004 if we
assume the pattern continues let's add
another seventy-five let's add another
75 and then what will that give us
that'll give us four hundred and fifty
students in 2005 if we assume the
pattern continues and we're almost there
let's add a final seventy-five
seventy-five plus
450 if you had 50 get to 500 so it's
another 25 so it's 525 so that would be
the answer to our question if we assume
the pattern continued that 525 students
attended Einstein School in 2006